but no everything's bigger jordan has
really grown as a filmmaker it's just a
different style of filmmaking that he's
doing
jordan has a very specific vision but he
also is a really amazing collaborator he
always creates a space for all of us
[Music]
i tried to write a script i didn't know
how to pull off and then assemble the
team to help me pull it off
every single department is firing off
these huge big swings you're not trying
to rush it trying to get the moments
there's a value on what you're shooting
i mean like the whole crew engaged with
it differently it takes a village to
make a film here on nope we're all
important individually and in
combination that sense of respect and
integrity for all of us is hugely
important
the scale is so huge we're working with
65 mil and imax which is pretty rare my
films are always personal i think it
stands apart from my other films and
that it's a bigger adventure than i've
ever tried to tell and
thank you
i'm here on my day off because it's a
privilege to be on a set like this
everyone is just titans when it comes to
their jobs there's not that many
african-american directors out there
with an opportunity to do things at a
high level
the way he films the thought behind it
he hires you for a reason because he
trusts you for me it's a very surreal
experience to be working with jordan
field just to be able to see the mind
working
the growth going from us to this film
jordan pushing not in vain but like but
why not and then when you add someone
like hoyta to the equation there's
nothing like it
i could straightaway feel that jordan
challenge himself a lot he showed from
the outset that he was not afraid so it
always meant that i had to challenge
myself to come up with more interesting
ways to tell a story
every day of this shoot
we're making something new and special
and something that is a testament to why
i love movies
and i'll be talking about these days we
made this movie forever
[Music]
you